what's with the jeans Josh Brolin's like
that yeah Wow
he seems pretty normal dude well I did
not I did not expect that you should say
to him hey Hitler let's be friends hey
Hitler
so here's all something I want to bring
up about the hey Hitler and that is that
some people in a FedEx sort of way are
saying that they're hearing something
else they're like they're saying oh I
don't think she's saying hey Hitler I
think she's saying hey Hitler you know
it's clearly Hitler to me blogging what
I'm saying is that if that's what you're
hearing there and you're not hearing it
I asked you know what what are you here
here's another video of hers that she
put out what are you here here I don't
know I could be happy birthday to you
Nicholas doesn't sound like Nicholas to
me no I hear Nicholas big words and then
lips big words big words
dude no it just sounds it sounds like
really like a big what is going on with
this girl a lot
there's demon spells there's demons
there's wizards or excited door excited
people okay all right people seem like I
don't know man it sounds very bizarre
which is a weird way of communicating
let's say that let's say that yeah why
don't you let us know what you hear is
not hearing Nikolas okay well you hear
that I hear something else what do you
hear I hear big words like what mmm what
is it big words no no I want someone to
make a remix of you saying it now songs
in the oh really it's about it's your
turn no okay
yeah it's it's really it's really
bizarre I mean so now we have two
controversies for what she's saying
because there are people who swear she's
saying Hitler
hello it's Hitler yeah she's she's
talking at all Hitler
she got a bless as a Nick okay see this
is what I'm talking about why can't you
finally get some heat on that yeah okay
yeah thank you
yeah yeah which I think she is but she
is asking Adolphe Hitler for help
she is that guy Nathaniel's jerk help me
Hitler God blessing yeah yeah yeah God
is real and God blesses in it that was
when you could not believe name what
half-ounce was saying that's his name it
was really dumb yeah that is crazy talk
it was crazy
God got us a guy would never call you a
nigger but I'm repeating if you like the
newscast you're like what did the text
message say I'm telling you no the text
message said and then you're like don't
say God blesses a nigga you asked me
what the text message so that I'm
showing you our God that's that's a
really loaded question because it would
take a long time they answer you know
what for one says I'm not interested in
the story of a same Lee's story like
just let it go eyes there's a lot going
on that the thirty yards there is that
yeah yeah yeah something something's
wrong you're never gonna say it